Aaron Swartz was nothing short of a
child prodigy at the age of 14 he helped
create RSS a popular tool for keeping up
with the latest news and blog posts
before the Advent of social media he
formed a company that merged with Reddit
and is credited with making Reddit one
of the most popular sites on the
internet yet that's not what he was
known for he was known for his internet
activism which led to the ultimate
tragedy
I couldn't wait until the whole world
was on the internet and I never had to
call anybody again the computer was his
favorite toy growing up in a wealthy
suburb of Chicago his father worked in
the tech industry so computers were
always a part of his life they were also
a distraction from the serious bowel
condition that often crippled him with
stomach pain as a result he only ate
bland food like rice and pasta he hated
fruits and veggies
Aaron thought the internet was magical
one of the exciting things about
Wikipedia is that it doesn't just have
articles on you know 100 most popular
things or the Thousand most popular
things you can pick the most obscure
subject on the world and there's an
article about it because for everything
there's someone who cares a great deal
about it and that's what television
that's what radio doesn't provide but
the internet does yet he also felt there
were barriers that limited the ability
of people to share and distribute
knowledge freely like strict copyright
laws we have the right as American
citizens to have this sort of free and
open communication to share what we
think what we feel what we've created
and I think that's a huge part of our
culture this notion that become a
permission asking society that every
time you do something you have to ask
permission I mean that's you know the
that's basically against the freedom
culture we have here that's the opposite
of a free country
Aaron believed no one should be deprived
of information and sought to break down
barriers he dropped out of Stanford
after a year to pursue his interest in
Internet freedom in 2008 he wrote this
Manifesto information is power but like
all power there are those who want to
keep it for themselves the world's
entire scientific and cultural heritage
published over centuries in books and
journals is increasingly being digitized
and locked up by a handful of private
corporations we need to take information
wherever it is stored make our copies
and share them with the world that year
he took on the US government's online
court record system Pacer which stores
information about cases court filings
and docket details he was frustrated
that Pacer charged for documents eight
cents per page at the time 10 cents
today Aaron believed the documents
should be free because they were
produced at the taxpayers expense so he
set out to republish these documents on
a public website for anyone access
he visited one of the few public
libraries that did allow free downloads
of Pacer documents and installed code
he'd written to request a new document
every three seconds this way he got his
hands on nearly 20 million pages of
documents or around 20 percent of the
database and uploaded the files to
Amazon's cloud computing service
when the court system's I.T Department
realized something was up the FBI got
involved and contacted Amazon which
provided his name phone number and
address as their user agreement allows
them to do so at the government's
request Aaron recalled in an interview I
had this vision of the feds crashing
down the door taking everything away
the feds investigated but didn't
prosecute him two years later it would
be a different story when authorities
say he hacked the servers at MIT to
steal millions of files from a digital
library
in September 2010 Federal authorities
say Aaron broke into mit's computer
network by accessing a restricted
utility closet on campus in the basement
of Building 16 which housed Network
equipment and cabling the room was
reportedly left unlocked he hardwired
his laptop into the network and hid it
under a cardboard box the laptop ran a
script called
keepgrabbing.py which set it to
automatically download academic journals
from the digital library jstor Aaron
used a guest account to access jstor at
the time any computer connected to mit's
open wireless network could access the
digital library
many institutions pay a lot of money so
their students can subscribe for free
otherwise plans for individuals cost
19.50 a month for just 10 PDF downloads
he created the fake guest identity Gary
host which prompted the computer network
to identify his computer as ghost when
shortened an apparent reference to its
ability to disappear
although Aaron used a legitimate guest
account he violated jstor's terms of use
by using an automated program to access
articles at one point he downloaded
about 700 articles a minute between
September 2010 to January 2011 he
downloaded nearly 5 million articles or
80 percent of jstor's database valued at
hundreds of thousands of dollars
a Federal indictment claims he intended
to upload all of the documents to a
peer-to-peer file sharing site where
anyone could access them for free but he
never got the chance
jstor noticed the huge spike in
downloads and alerted MIT which launched
an investigation alongside the Cambridge
Police Department and the U.S Secret
Service blocking the IP address from
which the requests originated didn't
work the person responsible simply
switched IPS to continue the mass
downloading a second computer then
connected to mit's network both laptops
downloaded articles at such a staggering
rate that several of jstores servers
crashed jstor then blocked access to all
MIT users for several days
on January 4 2011 authorities discovered
a laptop hidden in the utility closet in
building 16. they decided to leave the
laptop in place to see if the person who
put it there would return they also
installed a hidden camera in the closet
to identify the intruder 30 minutes
later Aaron is captured on video
entering the closet to purportedly
replace the hard drive
the video you're watching was originally
published by wired.com which obtained it
through a Freedom of Information Act
lawsuit against the U.S Secret Service
two days later on January 6 2011 someone
entered the closet again covering their
face with a bike helmet they removed the
laptop and hard drive and left the MIT
police were unable to reach the closet
in time to apprehend the person but the
suspect didn't leave the campus
immediately the same laptop then
connected to mit's Student Center
perhaps to access the network from a
different location to avoid detection
later that afternoon an MIT police
officer who saw the surveillance footage
recognized the same guy riding his bike
on campus when the officer approached
Aaron Aaron leaped off his bike and ran
away
but MIT police in a secret service agent
caught up with him and arrested him for
breaking and entering at the time of his
arrest Aaron was found to possess a USB
drive containing the program
keepgrabbing.py the same software
program found on the laptop in the
closet there was no doubt they had the
right person
attorney's office in Boston charged
Aaron with numerous counts of wire fraud
and violating the computer fraud in
Abuse Act the charges carried a maximum
sentence of 35 years in prison in a fine
of up to one million dollars
his supporters called it ludicrous they
argued he simply wanted to make academic
research more widely available they
believe the punishment didn't fit the
crime
however Carmen Ortiz the then U.S
attorney for the District of
Massachusetts who oversaw Aaron's
prosecution argued stealing is stealing
whether you use a computer command or a
crowbar and whether you take documents
data or dollars
jstor chose not to press charges after
Aaron turned over his hard drives the
prosecution offered Aaron a plea deal
had he accepted it he would have gone to
prison for only six months his
girlfriend Taryn reflected on the
difficult decision he had to make
it just the whole thing
was so hard and so stressful and he felt
he carried so much of the weight of it
on his own
he didn't want to involve any of his
friends
he wanted to protect people but he
wasn't very good at protecting himself
Aaron refused the plea bargain because
he didn't want to be labeled a felon a
close friend and former girlfriend
recalled to Rolling Stone how they were
standing outside the White House one day
when Aaron turned to her and said you
know they don't allow felons to work
there
at the time he was charged he had been a
research fellow at Harvard Harvard then
suspended his fellowship and banned him
from campus
Aaron settled into a studio apartment in
Brooklyn awaiting trial he grew
increasingly isolated and depressed he
had struggled with depression for years
often triggered by Islamic issues
long before the jstor incident he wrote
A Blog on his personal website that
described his State of Mind go outside
and get some fresh air or cuddle with a
loved one and you don't feel any better
only more upset at being unable to feel
the joy that everyone else seems to feel
everything gets colored by the sadness
you feel as if streaks of pain are
running through your head you thrash
your body you search for some Escape but
find none
on January 11 2013 Aaron Swartz was
found dead in his apartment in New York
City he was 26 years old
but I think he woke it up two years
after this ordeal started and I think he
just couldn't face another day of the
stress
the uncertainty the lack of control of
her his own destiny
Aaron's partner and family blamed his
death on prosecutors declaring in a
statement Aaron's death is not simply a
personal tragedy it is the product of a
criminal justice system Rife with
intimidation and prosecutorial overreach
decisions made by officials in the
Massachusetts U.S attorney's office and
at MIT contributed to his death there
were calls for U.S attorney Carmen Ortiz
to be removed she defended her handling
of the case this way
this office sought an appropriate
sentence that matched the alleged
conduct a sentence that we would
recommend to the judge of six months in
a low security setting his defense
counsel would have been free to
recommend a sentence of probation at no
time did this office ever seek or ever
tell Mr Schwartz's attorneys that it
intended to seek maximum penalties under
the law
Aaron leaves a lasting Legacy he was an
early contributor to the development of
the Creative Commons license which
provides a legal framework for creators
to share their work with others under
certain conditions it has since become
an important tool for promoting open
access to information his goal all along
I have personally benefited from the use
of Creative Commons without access to
this vast library of free and open
content I would have had to spend a lot
more time sourcing material making
videos like this one much more difficult
to produce Aaron's belief in limiting
the power of Institutions has influenced
debates on free speech and whether
social media companies have gone too far
in censoring information he had
co-founded an advocacy group dedicated
acting civil liberties and fighting
censorship
people often ask me you know what's
going to happen and the answer is it's
up to you right you get to decide what
will happen this isn't something playing
out on a stage somewhere where big
giants fight each other and you get to
sit and Munch popcorn this is a fight
you can join in it's up to you
like
the case against Aaron wasn't the first
of its kind to Challenge online Civil
Disobedience the same year of Aaron's
death Ross ulbricht was arrested and
charged with running the dark web Online
Marketplace Silk Road
the harsh sentence Ross received has
been the topic of widespread discussion
you can check out my video on that which
I've Linked In My description
[Music]
the computer skills of Aaron Swartz and
Ross Albrecht played a huge role in
their attempt to change the world
although their actions led to legal
consequences their stories demonstrate
the power that stem can have to make an
impact
well brilliant.org is a website and app
where you can learn science computer
science and math interactively my
viewers especially love their computer
science courses they're great whether
you're starting out or if you want to
brush up on your skills you can dive
deeper into more advanced topics as you
progress through their lessons
Brilliance supports you every step of
the way if you're stuck you can view the
explanation to see where you went wrong
there are thousands of courses to choose
from everything from foundational in
advanced math to data science I
personally use brilliant to go through
their logic puzzles to improve my
analytical thinking
brilliant is free for you to try out for
30 days if you head to my custom link in
the description
brilliant.org newsthink and the first
200 people who sign up with my link will
get 20 off their annual subscription
thanks for watching I'm Cindy Palm
foreign